[Music]
the habits and the actions you have with
money will Outlast you
[Music]
margin gives you options
and options gives you freedom
can't hate or rage your way to peace and
prosperity
you work too hard for too long to live
for the weekend
if you will live like no one else later
you can live and give like no one else
well we want you to begin to build
wealth so that you can change your
family tree
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome to
the stage Dave Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome you guys
thank you thank you guys
wow
wow is it too late in January to say
Happy New Year
yeah I mean 2023 is here
thank you Jesus
I mean I mean we had 2020 and we thought
wow 2021's got to be better and it said
no hold my beer oh my gosh
you know and then 2020 it just it just
keeps going it's amazing so we're so
happy to have a brand new year a clean
slate a fresh start which is Grace in
its best form you know it just I get a
new shot at this thing and so when you
Google you know people that that Google
dieting for instance at the beginning of
the year it's like 82 percent
every I mean it goes way up you know
just on a Federal holiday 10 do right
getting out of debt getting control of
my money learning to save money all way
up at the beginning of the year our
hopes are up
but these are weird times
it's dark out there
it's scary out there it's uncertain out
there and people are afraid
and I've been there I know what it feels
like to be afraid and if you want to get
healthy in these areas life change
in any area of your life your marriage
your parenting your spiritual walk your
money is an intentional act no one
accidentally wins
Super Bowl will be in a few weeks and at
the end of the Super Bowl there'll be
confetti And the reporter will run over
and ask the guy how did you win the
Super Bowl he never says I just got off
the bus I don't know what happened
it's an intentional Act
since he was six years old
he's been probably playing that position
or something like it all the way up
through college and he's one of the few
that gets out of college and goes to the
big leagues to the NFL right and
actually gets to play at that level it's
not an accident to win it's not an ax
accident to be married today 50 years
it requires
extreme patience
and understanding which is what my wife
said for me to say so I did
if you want to get healthy
it's an intentional Act
no one accidentally gets in shape
if you want a great marriage if you want
a great if you want to build some wealth
so you can be outrageously generous it's
an intentional
Act
over the years of teaching this stuff
for the last 30 years I've done a spoken
in a lot of different settings and
speaking of the NFL I was speaking for
an NFL team they do a thing called
rookie camp and they bring in these
rookies who are making more money than
they've ever made in their lives and
their eyes are full of stars and dollar
signs and Mercedes-Benz and houses for
their mama and so on right and they've
got all these big ideas and they have no
idea that money's really not going to go
that far and so they bring me in to
spray cold water on the whole idea
because I'm good at it so the first
thing I explain to them is NFL stands
for not for long
the NFL average NFL career is 3.7 years
and 78 of them leave the league
permanently physically disabled
and the divorce rate is fourfold the
national average and within 10 years the
bankruptcy rate is fourfold the national
average so it's not a great blessing
when you hear those statistics but
you've got a choice in the matter if
you're the son the daughter sitting
there wouldn't be a daughter in this
game but I mean if you're the guys
sitting there you've got a choice so I
finished the talk walked them through
the whole thing all the Ramsey stuff
that we talk about common sense what
grandma said what God says in the Bible
about money which turns out to be the
same things right I finished the talk
and leaning against the back wall is
this guy now I don't I'm a football fan
but I with her helmet I mean I know if
they got their name on the back I know
who it is right but I don't know their I
mean I pass them in the store they're
big but I mean you you probably play
football yeah I mean you have no idea
and so uh but there's a guy at the back
and he's like
Hall of Famer I recognized him he's one
of those guys and he's he snuck in the
rookie Camp hear the talk and uh so I
kind of called on him and he's obviously
a veteran player and I said so tell
these guys am I right he goes oh you're
so right
he goes a number of you that will be
standing back here at the back of the
room at my age is very small so take
advantage of the money while it's coming
in dude and he gave good follow-up talk
right so I get to the end of it I'm
talking to him back there because he was
dead on very articulate and I was
talking to this guy in a future Hall of
Famer I can't say his name because I
don't have permission to tell the story
I didn't ask you but it's a great still
a great story so I'm telling anyway but
um
I said I all that stuff aside I said I
watch football and I'm a mediocre at
best athlete in a couple of things not
at football but I I
I just I as a fan can I ask you a
question
and he said sure and I said well I it's
you know it may be one of those weird
fan questions I'll warn you ahead of
time and he goes it's okay we're just
like just me you and you hanging out we
don't have to if I tell you if it's
stupid I'll just tell you I said okay
I said so you get paid like
10 million 20 million 30 million dollars
a year whatever it is somewhere in there
to do one thing
catch
a football
how is it pray tell that when a if
you've ever seen a quarterback if you
stood on the sidelines NFL when they're
throwing a football it's so fast
if you've ever caught a football it
hurts terribly they can total a car with
a football I mean the speed is blinding
it's it's a physical act that's why
those it's amazing I said so if he
throws the ball so hard it drills a hole
in your soul
numbers and you're paid 25 million
dollars to catch a football and that's
your only thing you do in life why is it
how is it that you would drop the
football
because as a fan I'm going you just hit
him in the numbers
he goes oh that's easy happens all the
time I went oh good he's not going to
kill me
he has just two things
he said both of them come to come down
to one thing he said it's loss of focus
I said okay so what's the two things he
goes well that's the things that coach
would cause you to lose your focus okay
this is getting philosophical I like
this probably theological it'll probably
preach
and he said he said so the first thing
calls you to lose your focus is fear
he said uh he goes I weigh 210 220 Maybe
six foot and some change and when I go
up after a ball the guy that's going to
hit me weighs three and a quarter
375 and he is running at the speed of a
Kia
and when I you know have you ever heard
he said have you ever heard the
announcer say oh he dropped the ball
because he heard footsteps he goes that
ain't a metaphor
you hear Sasquatch coming
boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom Crush I'm gonna be in an ice bath
tomorrow and six massages later I'm
gonna try to walk out onto the practice
field and try to get ready to do that
again next week he goes and in a
nanosecond your brain tells you this is
getting ready to happen and you drop the
football
so shut up
fear
causes you to lose your focus
he said here's the other one have you
ever seen the receiver Dave running down
the field there's nobody around him
except the end zone is right there he
the fall is coming and he's looking and
he's got it and he's like I just got to
catch it and already in his mind you see
me starting to do his touchdown dance
only the end Zone's still there
and he ain't got there yet
and he's all he he's already and he
trips and falls or misses the ball
because he's already in the end zone in
his mind instead of finishing the job
he said that's called greed
greed will cause you to lose your focus
fear and greed
will cause you to lose your focus no not
greed like money but greed like I'm
celebrating something that I haven't yet
earned
fear greed these things will mess you up
when you sense disaster when you've got
fear your brain shuts down Dr John
Delaney talks about that all the time
here at Ramsey you're the parts of your
brain shut down because you are in fight
or flight you got to get out of the way
the car is getting ready to run over you
you don't need to have a discussion
about what type of car it is
is it electric is it a Tesla I know get
out of the road
your brain shuts down your thinking
skills your higher thinking skills your
critical thinking skills go away and you
flee so you don't get hit by the car
you don't get eaten by the Sabretooth
that's where it comes from that part of
your brain right and so this idea that
fear is okay and we become fear junkies
in this culture just look at the news
channels everything is something to make
you angry greedy afraid angry greedy
afraid these are not fruits of the
spirit angry free Angry free to your
grave yeah all that stuff right can't
even say it anymore it's so bad but this
fear thing
is real and the numbers are
devastating
and we've been fighting fear from covet
pandemic to quarantine and losing a job
first we thought we were going to die
then we thought we were going to not
have a job because some people thought
we were going to die and then you
couldn't get nothing and then you could
get everything but it was all overpriced
and then you can't get nothing but now
it's overpriced again and I I'm never
going to get a house
I'm never gonna get out
and we get in this crazed mode the
anxiety level is so high and with that
going on for so long now we've gone
through like three or four events back
to back to back now we're in this
inflation mess we've got this
divisiveness and this anger in this
country where everyone's just they cut
people completely out of their lives
because of who they think they might
have voted for
it's nuts people have lost their dadgum
minds there's no Grace there's no mercy
there's no kindness and gentleness it's
just I mean it's all driven by this fear
of fatigue and greed and if you stay if
you stay afraid long enough fatigue sets
in and General George Patton said
fatigue
makes cowards of us all
tired people are short-tempered tired
people aren't thinking clearly man if I
just get hungry I get mean
much less hungry and Power and then you
put me in traffic with an idiot in front
of me oh my goodness
are you all that way I mean and it and
this has just been amped up
for about 36 months y'all know what I'm
talking about and it's coming to a head
on our culture and we need to address it
head on we need to say it out loud and
go hey the emperor has no clothes this
is not good
this is this is not good as a people we
need to reset spiritually emotionally
from our mental health standpoint and it
does revolve around our money revolves
around wealth building so I'm afraid I'm
going to go into recession I'm afraid
I'm going to lose a job I'm afraid I'm
going to end up in a van down by the
river
so tonight
gonna opt out
gonna step back
get a little different perspective
different look on things
how are Americans feeling about Building
Wealth right now
well we just finished a huge survey with
Ramsey research and the numbers are
they're sad
State of the Union is not good I mean
it's like 1992 it's the economy stupid
I mean it really is that's this is what
people are worried about eight and ten
Americans are worried about the economy
inflation's at a 40-year high
here in 19 in 2022. the great
resignation people quitting their jobs
3.98 million people a month quit their
jobs in 2021.
oh it gets better 2022 4 million a month
did
and then if they didn't quit their jobs
they got fired
last year Facebook laid off 11 000
people Amazon laid off ten thousand
people Redfin laid off laid off a
thousand people and down in Mississippi
one Factory closed if you didn't read
about it back at uh Thanksgiving on
Monday night before Thanksgiving they
sent out an email and laid off 2 700
people they all went to work on Monday
when they got home Monday night there
was an email
you don't have a job anymore they shut
the whole Factory down that night as if
they didn't know
before that day
heartless
heartless
Salesforce their stock has gone down 38
in order to get their profitability up
their stock price off start laying off
people because their most expensive
thing is people
and you can get your profitability up in
Corporate America anytime you want to
just lower your payroll that's all you
got to do chop payroll your stock price
will go up
and guess what payroll is human
beings with families and kids and
mortgages and fears
and
that's not right
that's not right that's when Corporate
America has gone nuts and the weird
thing is Corporate America can be small
company big company the type of
corporate America I'm talking about the
yucky kind you can run a big company it
doesn't have to be run poorly
and it doesn't have to be done without
taking care of people it can be done
37 percent of Americans are struggling
or in crisis with their finances that's
a hundred million people
25 percent of Americans say they're
relying on credit to make ends meet boo
four in ten Americans say they have zero
in savings
half of Americans say they
finances have a negative
impact on their mental health four in
ten of you when we surveyed you said in
the last year you have cried over your
money or had I panic attack over your
money 40 percent
physically cried
these are your neighbors
the people you work with
and we lie I mean we lie in church how's
it going Dave just fine
cars going to be repoed Tuesday but just
fine
we cover it up but it's there and then
it boils up in the form of fatigue it
boils up in the form of fear it boils up
in the form of
anger
it boils up in greed looking for a
shortcut I'm watching a 23 year old 25
year old living in his mother's basement
on Tic Tac and now I got a whole new
clue on how to get money
yeah right
82 of Americans are somewhat or
extremely worried about their student
loan payments but don't worry Joe Biden
forgave them
oh wait a minute Supreme Court said hold
my beer
we'll see
so the numbers seem like they're stacked
up against us and this is a weird
Paradox all of this negative fear and
everything else around the whole idea of
money and about our futures and yet you
cannot get a parking space at the mall
or a reservation at a restaurant
that's a weird paradox I mean if you
went to Walmart you went to the you know
even a high-end store you got no idea
that anybody's worried about the economy
they're in there spending like Congress
I mean they are going bananas
and it's just this weird Paradox but
these are the actual numbers this is
what's going on
so what happens in a situation like this
is you get to the point you say
I'm sick
of this
I'm tired
of this
and my great friend The Fabulous
motivator from a whole nother decade or
two ago Les Brown said when you get sick
and tired of being sick and tired that's
when you finally say the magic words of
transformation
when you have
life is not an intellectual dance or
some kind of theoretical idea if you get
sick and tired of being sick and tired
I've had it
had it then you will change
American Express called my house when we
were going broke I was 28 years old
Rachel was a brand new baby my wife
would have left but she didn't have a
car
American Express called my house we were
going we were so broke it was awful I'd
done every stupid thing made Ramsay
callers look like Geniuses I had done
every stupid thing and the guy calls my
house and he's trying to collect 1166
dollars and 42 cents on an American
Express bill you know how I remember it
because I got so mad
because he asked my wife why she would
stay with a man that wouldn't pay his
bills
we don't do business with American
Express 40 years later I'll just tell
you that
still I was redneck Hill Billy hopping
mad ready to drive Jacksonville Florida
drag him out of his little cubicle and
beat the snot out of him
because she called me at the office
crying and said he said he said he said
would I stay with a man we wouldn't pay
his bills and I was thinking the same
thing
foreign
I was sick and tired of being sick and
tired I was mad I'd had it and I'm still
mad 40 years later and when I talked to
one of you and your life has been broken
over the knee of a credit card company
or broken over the knee of Sally May or
you've gotten yourself into a mess with
your own stupid butt choices same kind
of stuff I've done in my life I feel
exactly that same kind of anger for you
with you and sometimes a little bit at
you get it done fix it get mad it's time
to change something
thank you
we got this thing going around the
wishification of America where people
are I'm struggling and I'm burned out
you're not burned out
I had a guy working for me he goes I'm
burnt out I said it's impossible you're
never on fire
[Applause]
you're not burnt out
you don't have a plan you believe in
you don't think that when you do
something when you plant corn you're
going to grow corn you don't believe
that you're going to reap what you sow
and so you're sowing nothing or you're
sowing sparingly and you're going to
reap sparingly or you're going to reap
nothing burn out right now is code four
I don't have any hope
because I don't know what to do and I
feel stuck exhaustion is the exact same
physical manifestation as burnout your
body feels exactly the same when you're
exhausted but you're not burned out when
you're exhausted you're just tired
because you just worked your butt off
towards a goal and you knew if you keep
doing that long enough you're going to
get the goal you know if I keep doing
this I'm going to win if I keep doing
this I'm going to get there and that's
you don't burn out when you go to Hawaii
you don't burn out when you're getting
traction you don't burn out when you
paid off a debt last month and now you
got three more to go I'm not burned out
I'm getting it but when I don't think I
can ever get out no matter what I do
hope the government fixes my life now
you get burnt out because the government
had never fixed anything
they can't even fix their lives look at
them they're a dad blame mess up there
man it's the Island of Misfit Toys don't
wait on them to fix your life that's
crazy
so ask yourself why did I set out to
build wealth in the first place
well when Sharon I started it's because
we wanted to eat Friday
y'all ever been there
and then once we got we were eating
pretty regular on Friday one of her big
goals was go to the grocery store and
buy anything she wanted she said if I
can just do that I'll be rich
and uh that was a long time ago she can
do that a lot now
we got Financial Peace
Life's good
it's 30 years later now
after going broke
so that's the first thing then after
that you start going hey man you know
maybe we can save up some money and if
there's an emergency every time the
tire's flat it won't be a freaking
crisis
you know wouldn't it be nice to have
something happen it'd be an
inconvenience
instead of a drama and then once we get
past that then we could do this and then
we could do that and man we could change
our family tree we could make so much
money no matter how stupid our kids are
they could mess it up
I mean that's possible
I mean well some of you it's not but I
mean it's
yes but wow some of them got exponential
abilities there but
but you know I better future for my my
family I want to be able to give
I want to be able to give this much I
want to make an impact
those around me I don't ever want to
walk up beside someone and I see that
look you see that look in their eyes
and I don't have the money to help them
I'll be able to just help them
I'm talking about that look
not the one who's begging
but the ones got that look like I don't
know what I'm going to do
I'm so scared I can't breathe and you
put tires on the single mom's car and
you filler car with gas and you tell the
mechanic to go through and make sure
everything's fixed the whole deal don't
cost you a thousand dollars
changes her whole life
because you never think about it anymore
because you've got your act together
this is when wealth building gets fun
y'all this is when it gets fun
it's not a
it's not a shortcut it's not a hack
there's no technique there's some
principles you follow those principles
they work every stinking time and 100 of
the time they are hard God and Grandma
were not in the business of lazy people
winning
Grandma kick some of your butts the way
y'all act standing around looking for
something for nothing I'm gonna work
from home and not
work
while I'm at home
but get paid that's called stealing
it's a different thing y'all this is old
school stuff these principles are what
brought us to this great place in this
country and abandoning them are a
problem
we cannot abandon them there's no secret
live on lesson you make
change everything when you get sick and
tired of being sick and tired and you
say I've had it you look in the driveway
and you go 750 bucks a month what was I
thinking
apparently I wouldn't
car sold
what was up I mean you look over there
you go I'm gonna sell that kids are
hiding by now they're starting to think
they're up for sale
right some of you when dinner time comes
around you don't know how to make
anything except reservations
you might want to fix that
it's expensive not against restaurants
but broke people shouldn't eat out all
the time hello
why is this hard it's not hard except
the culture has been told they can do
anything they want and there's no
repercussions of course there's
repercussions
of course when you violate the law of
gravity you're going to go Splat on the
sidewalk dummy that's the way it works
just I'm man I tell you I love getting
people fired up on this because it sets
them free when you finally say I've had
it it changes everything
my friend Jim Collins wrote a fabulous
book on leadership called good to Great
many of you have read it I'm sure it's a
classic by now millions and millions of
copies sold and one of the things he
talked about in there was the Stockdale
paradox
and the way he got that phrase Jim's a
big researcher was he interviewed the
famous Admiral Admiral Stockdale who was
a pow in Vietnam now during the Vietnam
era the Pow Camp was in Hanoi
the hanawei prison which means Hell's
Hole
or fiery furnace
and it was nicknamed the Hanoi Hilton
sarcastically by the pows the prisoners
of War many of the pows were fighter
pilots they were shot down their capture
Center John McCain was one he was there
in solitary confinement two of the five
years he was there
so in the Hanoi Hilton it was a a place
of torture
prisoners were regularly tortured every
day
they were starved to death many many
many
died
they were put in solitary confinement
they were beaten they were suffering all
the time
Stockdale was a commander when his plane
was shot down he was captured he later
after coming home became an admiral
he was in prison for eight years and
tortured 20 times during that time
incredible horrific thing many strong
men many brave men did not make it out
of the Hanoi Hilton and when
uh Collins was interviewing Stockdale
about this process he's trying to
understand the human Spirit here he said
how did you make it out of life and
Stockdale said I never lost faith
in the end of the story
I never doubted not only that I would
get out but that I would also Prevail in
the end and turn the experience into the
defining event of my life which in
retrospect I would not trade
Collins looked at him and said well who
didn't make it out
he said oh that's easy the Optimus
didn't make it out
the guys who said oh we're gonna be home
by Christmas and then they weren't
oh we're gonna be home by Thanksgiving
and then they weren't we'll be home by
Easter and then we weren't we'll be home
by and then and they died of a broken
heart
he said this is the very important
lesson you must never confuse faith that
you will prevail in the end with the
discipline to confront the most brutal
facts in your current reality whatever
they might be Collins calls this the
Stockdale paradox
your have faith in the end of the story
but I'm going to convey I'm going to
face the brutal facts of what I have got
to do to get to the end of the story
I've got to sell the car I've got to
work an extra job I've got to learn a
new word in my house the ancient word
I'll teach it to you
you press your tongue towards the top of
your mouth you release it you make a
kissing motion with your lips it sounds
like this no
it's a powerful word it will release you
from this culture no
you can say no I'm sorry if you want to
soften it
but at the Ramsay house no is a complete
sentence
even with the grandbabies Papa Dave said
I'm that guy
I love you
you will kill yourself you cannot play
with that no I'm here to protect you
you're small and dumb no
I love you more than life itself no
no
and then you look in the mirror and you
go no because adults devise a plan and
follow it
children
do what feels good
when I was going broke I four o'clock in
the morning I sat down in my recliner
with my Bible and it flopped open
randomly to Romans and of course it
wasn't random it was God going hello and
uh
Romans 5 3-5 rejoice in your suffering
now I know many of you are reverent in
your walk with the Lord and I am most
the time but right then I wasn't feeling
really reverent rejoice in your
suffering and I went no thanks
don't think so I'm upset at this right
now and no thanks I think I'm going to
move on to another scripture this one
doesn't appeal
rejoice in your suffering
keep reading
because suffering
produces perseverance
and perseverance character and character
hope
and hope does not disappoint it's a gift
of the Holy Spirit
hope comes from God
so in a land where we've lost our hope
and instead we're dependent on fear and
anger and greed
we can step aside from that step back
get a new perspective and say
I'm going to lean into hope I'm going to
confront the brutal facts of the
mistakes I've made and things I've got
to do to undo them and to commence I
have to clean up
but I'm also going to have faith in the
end of the story
because I've read the back of the book
and ladies and gentlemen we win
[Applause]
so I want to bring up a real treat for
you tonight one of our one of the top
Ramsay personalities we've got right now
everywhere he goes people are just
loving this guy he's really on fire he's
a hard-working dude behind the scenes
learn everything we're doing inside and
out he and my daughter Rachel have just
launched a new podcast that has gone
explosive the numbers are amazing if you
haven't listen to it I listened to it
this morning one of them came out today
called smart money happy hour and it's
two goofy guys and or two goofy people
having a blast and it's fun and funny
and there's information in there too so
you don't want to miss it it's good
they're very very good and you're going
to really enjoy him please welcome to
the stage Georgetown more
thank you Dave thank you thank you
well it is a big day for gingers any
gingers in the crowd
as rhetorical we see you it's very
obvious
January 12th national Kiss a Ginger Day
I cannot make this up
and I assume it was invented by just a
real desperate Ginger fella who needed a
holiday just to get a little kiss
but January 12th is also special to me
as a non-ginger exactly one year ago
today January 12 2022 my wife and I did
our debt free scream right up there on
the Ramsey Show because we paid off our
house
thank you
now I'm not special I'm not rich I don't
have a trust fund I don't have a rich
Uncle my uncle's broke this was a
journey for us
and uh you know just like getting to
five foot six it took a lot of time and
hard work to get here the doctor says
there's still hope
but here's what's crazy about my story
over the past 10 years of following the
Ramsay baby steps I went from a negative
net worth to a baby steps millionaire
that boggles my mind
so I am living proof that you guys can
do this stuff too you see I'm a first
generation American which means I was
born in the U.S my parents were not they
came from the Middle East back in the
1980s and so like none of you I grew up
Arabic Baptist
it's a real thing you can Google it and
if you're wondering like what that's
like growing up Arabic Baptist imagine
Baptist plus hummus
that's the recipe delicious
so my parents quickly conformed to the
American culture when they got here what
does that mean you conform to the money
culture too don't you
the one that says payments are normal
your FICO score is Almighty and college
education is worth it no matter how many
Sallie Mae Monopoly dollars it takes to
get there
and so naturally I fell for those traps
too so by 2013 I found myself 36
000 in student loan debt four thousand
dollars in credit card debt and here's
me back in 2013. check this out
yeah don't laugh it's not a funny photo
gosh
well behind that ever so gentle smile
and that single-use h m cardigan was a
guy who truthfully was frustrated and
anxious and feeling a little bit
hopeless
and here's why like many of you I did
everything you were supposed to do right
I was part of the generation that was
told if you work hard and you get good
grades and go to the college that you
want at all costs and get the credit
cards for the cash back and the airline
miles and the credit score and you wish
upon a star that would make no
difference who you are anything your
heart desires will come to you your
dreams dreams would come true right but
it was a nightmare
instead of a real boy I turned out to be
real broke
not what you want
now thankfully Ramsey Solutions
intersected my life that year I landed a
temp job here a decade ago and I went
through this money course called
Financial Peace University all heard of
it
it's famous it's famous and it changed
everything y'all in that course my
entire Paradigm shifted I learned that
this this money culture this financial
system is actually designed to screw you
over
yeah it turns out a life of payments
makes Banks and lenders rich and they
get fancy buildings and they sponsor
stadiums and it keeps us broke
and I learned that if you want to win
with money you got to figure out what
everyone else is doing and then run in
the other direction
and that's what I did 18 months later
going all in on these baby steps I cut
up the cards and I paid off forty
thousand dollars in Consumer Debt I was
debt free
Felt So Good
now can you all imagine if I had waited
in 2013 10 years for student loan
forgiveness
well you don't have to imagine because
10 years later I'd still be waiting it's
like that scene Bueller
Biden
Biden
nothing nothing
now I want to show you
the difference between 2013 George and
the George of today
this is me and my wife paying off our
house and that is a different feeling
right there
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah more joy I have less anxiety with
money I have more hope for my financial
future than ever
stuff works and you can do it too you
can go from negative net worth to
millionaire but you got to be willing to
swim upstream to be a little weird to
create to create the right money habits
that's what I want to talk to you about
tonight you came here because you want
some hope that it's still possible to
build wealth in today's America but like
Dave said it's crazy times
everything is still so freaking
expensive inflation is out of control
and the last semblance of hope that we
have is the Costco hot dog still hanging
on for dear life a dollar fifty for
almost 40 years
but you all know it's a trap right
because it's illegal to leave Costco for
less than 150.
that's a trap
but Costco aside everything else has
gone up and it's really got me down
I mean y'all feel me you know this life
is good right we got contentment we got
gratitude but it's been hard
for so many people out there
it's been stressful Money's been tight
you thought life would look differently
by now
you thought you'd be in a different spot
financially and now it feels like you
might never get ahead with money
and your money stretched then of course
thanks to inflation and payments and
child care and your lifestyle and your
subscriptions and the list goes on
but that means your feeling stretched
then too
and as I've been taking calls on the
Ramsey Show
helping people with their money problems
a lot of the calls boil down to one main
issue margin
too much month at the end of the money
that's the real reason they're stressed
and out of control and anxious and
feeling stuck and unable to pay for
emergencies unable to build wealth for
the future
so what is margin exactly
well margin is breathing room right in
your bank account and your life it's
knowing your card's not going to get
declined at the grocery store
it's having money left over abundance to
give to save to spend
and margin is also the key to maximizing
your number one wealth building tool
your income so how do we get this margin
well it takes a little bit of math
here's the formula for margin it's going
to blow your mind get this
spend less
plus make more
equals margin thank you for coming to my
TED talk it's been a pleasure it's been
a pleasure now let's be honest this is
easier said than done if it was easy
we'd all have it wouldn't we it takes
sacrifice it takes some compromise it
takes living on less than you make takes
getting out of your comfort zone
so I want to share three key steps to
create margin so that you can actually
build wealth the first step is to start
a zero based budget
now if your income is your number one
wealth building tool your budget is
second
why is that well it allows you to get
your spending under control and create a
habit of saving
and a budget is just telling your money
where to go instead of wondering where
it went
and get this when people start Financial
Peace University they start budgeting
they're using every dollar on average
they find 350 dollars in their budget in
their first month of budgeting that was
just floating away from them they took
control
when you do a budget you will feel like
you got a raise you don't need an
awkward conversation with your boss
and it turns out when you pay attention
to your money it starts to behave
doesn't it
self-control and discipline that's what
budgeting is just adulting with your
money
now if you're married you've got to be
doing a budget together this is a team
effort like folding fitted sheets nobody
should attempt it alone it's too
dangerous
now earlier I told you my wife and I we
paid off our house and there's no way we
could have done this without being on
the same page
we reach our goals so much faster when
we work with our spouse not in spite of
them
it's one of the main calls we got on the
Ramsey show how do I get on the same
page with my spouse
well it takes hard conversations it
takes actually having a vision for your
marriage instead of wondering what's
happening next weekend thinking about
what you want the next five years to
look like it takes going through
Financial Peace University to create
common language and shared goals around
money
and here at Ramsey Solutions we've got
the best budgeting method out there it's
called a zero-based budget this is where
your income minus expenses equals zero
let me show you what this looks like
let's say we make four thousand dollars
we list our income on one side that's
all the paychecks for the month the
other side is all of our expenses so go
through that bank statement and take
your best guess at what that month is
going to look like and it should come
down to zero you'll notice right now we
got money left over our expenses are 3
600. so with that extra 400 bucks we got
to give that a job otherwise it's going
to float away into ubereats and doordash
and Target
and so we're going to apply that 400
bucks to our baby step we're trying to
get out of debt great now we've got a
zero base budget every dollar has a job
we don't like our dollars unemployed
right
now we have a free app called every
dollar that makes this super easy you
download it you set up your budget
minutes you track it throughout the
month and that is the way it works now
once we get the budget going the second
step to creating margin is to get out of
debt
turns out it's real difficult to build
for the future while still paying for
the past
you're getting tugged in two directions
don't wonder why you can't build wealth
when you've got payments up to your
eyeballs the credit card bills the car
payments your student loan payments yes
they are coming back regardless of how
long Uncle Joe kicks the can down the
road
so here's an exercise if you're not mad
at your debt and you're like well my
payments are comfortable here's a fine
exercise for you
add up how much you pay in payments
every single month
now add up the interest you're paying
every single month now multiply that by
12 months now you want to punch me
you're so angry please don't
debt is robbing your paycheck it's
robbing your joy and it's robbing your
ability to build wealth
and for most people debt is truly the
biggest roadblock to Building Wealth
we can complain about inflation in the
economy in the white house but when we
look at our house and we look at that
guy in the mirror and you look at his
payments that's the real reason
and that's why we're going to get
completely debt free using the debt
snowball method it's the same method I
use to pay off 40 000 18 months here's
how it works we list out all of our
debts from smallest to largest
regardless of the interest rate if y'all
are so good at math we wouldn't be in
debt would we we're focusing on progress
here we want quick wins so we're going
to attack the little debt with a
Vengeance with all the margin we can
have we're selling stuff we're cutting
expenses rolling that payment into the
next one into the next one the Subaru's
getting paid off Sally May's evicted we
are debt free
just like that
it's that simple and it's that hard
because you got to realize oh my little
plan of moving the car to the zero
percent that's not actually doing
anything we got to get out of debt we
can't just move it around
so once we're out of debt we're
budgeting we can move on to the third
step to creating margin which is get
that emergency fund so once your debt
free it's your next priority three to
six months of expenses in a rainy day
emergency fund and notice I said
expenses not income so look at your
living expenses what do you need to
survive for a month multiply that out
and this is really a buffer between you
and life so that you never have to go
into debt again you're wondering how
does this help me create margin well it
keeps you from going back into debt
which helps you keep the margin you work
so hard to create
so let's define emergency real quick
because some of y'all get it twisted
because you get a sale to your favorite
store in your email and you're like it's
an emergency they'll never do 30 off
again
and by the way upgrading to the latest
iPhone not an emergency
unless you're an Android User in which
case it might be an emergency
it might be
I don't know
and that is how you lose half the crowd
you're welcome
so those are the three steps to creating
margin and we got to remind ourselves
why are we doing this
to reduce money stress and put ourselves
in a position to build wealth
now think about where you are for a
second if you do all those three things
you've got a consistent monthly plan for
your money you've got no payments and
you have 10 15 20 25
000 in the bank for emergencies
breathe that in
no amount of meditation or goat yoga
will give you that kind of Zen
that is why we call it Financial Peace
you make decisions differently you give
differently you spend differently
now you might be saying to yourself well
George you just did that in three
seconds this sounds gonna take forever I
got a lot of debt man I don't make that
much how am I going to do this
well I'll tell you when you go all in on
this plan here's the timeline for how
long it takes on average baby step one
is a starter emergency fund of a
thousand bucks people do that in 30 days
max because we are selling stuff we're
working side jobs we're cutting expenses
down to nothing to get that thousand
bucks fast
second the baby step two getting out of
the Consumer Debt it takes people 18 to
24 months on average with that gazelle
intensity
baby step three fully funded emergency
fund six months on average to get that
saved up so think about this two two and
a half years of short-term sacrifice to
build an incredible foundation for
long-term wealth building
now we're actually ready to build wealth
baby step four we start investing 15 of
our household income in retirement now
I'm going to keep it real simple here
because a lot of your friends out there
think their whole life insurance plan
they want to sell you is an investment
vehicle and they think crypto is an
investment vehicle and the single stock
that's going to take off and go to the
Moon is an investment vehicle no
it's this simple all you need to build
wealth is a 401k
and an IRA
in 2019 Ramsey Solutions did the largest
study of millionaires ever done over 10
000 of them and here was a shocker the
number one investment vehicle to become
a millionaire was a 401K plan
it's that boring and it gives me that
much hope that I can do it too
and here's a five-word investing
strategy
that sums up everything we believe in at
Ramsey about investing match beats Roth
beats traditional
so let's walk through that for starters
you're going to invest up to the match
if you have one in your 401k or if
you're a military or government you
might have a tsp if you're a teacher you
might have the 403 b the match is a 100
return on your investment you put in
four they match four take that first
that's amazing it's an awesome benefit
to have thank you HR we love you they
don't get thanked a lot it turns out
usually they just get complaints about
Gary and shipping so they could use a
win
so if you have the option of a
traditional 401K we're investing up to
the match then we're going to move on to
Roth options what does Roth mean it's
real simple you're using after tax
dollars that grow tax-free we love that
you got a million dollars in Roth at
retirement you get a million dollars
without Uncle Sam touching it ever again
so we're going to max out a Roth and if
we're still not at 15 yet we're going to
go back and invest in that workplace
retirement plan until we get there and
if you have a Roth 401k we love that you
can just invest all 15 there if you want
that's wonderful
so no matter where you are in your
wealth building journey I recommend
working with a financial advisor I've
got one Dave has one you need these
people in your corner not only to coach
you through the ups and downs to keep
you from jumping off the ledge but to
help you understand what you're
investing in don't do this blindly you
can connect with one all over the
country ramsaysolutions.com they're
fantastic and they give me so much
confidence in my wealth building Journey
now here's what's amazing to me in most
retirement accounts ninety percent of
the balance is growth when you get to
retirement
that is the power of compound interest
here's what that means you put in 10 is
what you contributed the rest was
compound interest that money making you
more money over time and you need a
long-term mindset to build wealth and
keep it we are not on this thing to get
rich quick the wisest and wealthiest guy
of all time Solomon said this in
Proverbs 13 11. wealth gained hastily
will dwindle but whoever gathers little
by little will increase it
that's fire I mean he would have crushed
it on Twitter let me tell you and he
could definitely afford that monthly
payment for the blue check oh I'm just
going to say that
that's the strategy right invest
consistently steadily over a long period
of time
so from what I just told you uh wealth
building really isn't that glamorous
it's actually pretty boring and that
gives me hope because I'm pretty boring
too I like it like that
you know it's not boring though having
no money stress retiring with dignity
having a few million bucks in the bank
instead of trying to survive off of
social insecurity
so let's look at what this looks like in
real life we're going to take a couple
Joe and Susie 32 years old
they just went through Financial Peace
University they're all in on the baby
steps and it takes them three years to
go from baby step one through baby step
three getting out of debt get the
emergency fund so now where are we at
they're 35 years old in baby step four
investing 15 of their income let's say
they make sixty five thousand dollars as
a household that's actually below the
median household income of 70.
now let's say they start investing at 15
percent
into mutual funds in their Roth 401k
that comes out to about a little over
800 bucks a month little under 10 grand
a year
and by the way that 800 bucks a month
exists because Joe and Susie created
margin in their finances by getting on a
budget and getting out of debt and
having money set aside for emergencies
so now let's pretend they don't even get
an employer match all right which is
unlikely because most employers have one
and they work their whole lives making
that below average household income and
they never get a raise for 30 years do
better Joe and Susie right
now the point of investing is of course
to make money and in a few minutes
Rachel Cruz will be out here talking
about how you actually make money in the
stock market she's going to ease your
fears around investing but let's run
some numbers out and see what Joe and
Susie's accounts will look like
investing at 800 bucks a month over 30
years with average returns of 10 to 12
percent
so 10 return they would have 1.8 million
dollars tax-free at retirement pretty
good right
let's bump it up to 11 let's be a little
optimistic 2.2 million bucks
now let's shoot for the stars and say
they get the average return 12 percent
2.8 million dollars
how much of that did Joe and Susie put
in less than 300 Grand
the rest was compound interest and it
only happened because they did this over
a long period of time now we can argue
about expense ratios and whatever you
all want to nerd out about but you got
to admit even if I'm half wrong on my
assumptions I'm not
you'd still be a baby steps millionaire
but here's what's more likely to happen
in reality Joe and Susie's income will
go up right which means they're going to
increase investing because of that
they're going to get the employer match
which means they're going to get free
money
they're going to pay off their house
early following the Ramsey Baby Steps in
about 10 to 15 years and that house is
going to appreciate in value over that
period of time
oh by the way once the house is paid off
they can increase investing
which means they're going to have way
more money than what I just showed you
but beyond the financial benefits here's
what they'll experience too a marriage
that's more likely to last
because they're on the same page with no
money fights and Money in the Bank
they're going to be more fulfilled in
their careers
because they're free to make decisions
without needing that next paycheck they
don't have to deal with that toxic boss
they just walk out of there and find a
different job
they also become more generous
because they have the margin to be
so when friends are family or their
Community needs help along with thoughts
and prayers they can also leave an
envelope of cash at the door how cool
would that be
don't you want that kind of life
that was rhetorical of course we do
that's what it looks like when you
decide to Rise Above This broken
Financial system and follow a proven
plan
change your future and you want to build
wealthy you got to turn off the noise
you got to turn off the news you got to
focus on creating the right money habits
focus on your house
so let's go back to this Tale of Two
Georges it's good to look back it's good
to remember that wealth building is a
journey and that Cardigans will
hopefully come back around
and 10 years for a lot of you might
sound like a long time I don't get that
kind of time well guess what it's going
to be here whether you like it or not
so what are you going to decide to do
that you're going to look back 10 years
from now and be grateful you did
and here's what happens right we've all
done the New Year's resolutions most
people overestimate what they can
accomplish in a year but they
underestimate what they can accomplish
in a decade
so my hope for you tonight is that you
decide to do the same plan that I did
that you discover the belief that you
can do this because it turns out the
little man still can get ahead in
America today
don't laugh
thank you
and it's not just me
it's you
big men too
but it starts with creating margin that
breathing room in your finances and it
is a different way to live when you
create that margin in your life and
here's what I found
margin gives you options and options
gives you freedom and freedom gives you
peace
and peace that gives you Joy and all of
that leads to a more meaningful life a
life well spent God bless you guys thank
you so much
thank you
now earlier I mentioned the stock market
can be a wild ride you might not like
what you see when you look at the 401K
and good news for you our next speaker
is going to give you the stock market
Survival Guide to ease your worries
she's a best-selling author host of The
Rachel Cruz show co-host of the Ramsay
Show and her finest career
accomplishment to date my co-host on our
newest podcast smart money happy hour
so would you help me welcome to the
stage my friend Rachel Cruz
thanks George great job great job hey
guys
okay so if I didn't have this job if
talking about money teaching about money
wasn't my job there's a couple other
things that I have in my life that I'm
like you know I feel like I would be
pretty great at uh one would be a
political correspondence
for a network I love politics so I'm
like I could totally I could do that uh
I could be a sleep trainer for babies
fantastic at getting babies to sleep
uh or a travel agent
and I love vacations I love traveling
this is like a spiritual gift of mine
okay so when our family is booking a
trip and planning a trip I'm like I am
all in or if we go on like a girls trip
or a couple's trip like I it's travel
agent Rachel is what everyone calls me
and like I was travel agent Rachel here
I'm like oh she's here she is here
and I just love it I love the details I
love looking at the flights and the
hotels I love making dinner reservations
researching the restaurants what we're
going to do I make an itinerary like
it's just it brings me life I don't know
so last year we decided to take our two
girls we have three kids but we decided
to take the two oldest the two girls to
Disney World
and I and Disney it's a pla it's a
planning kind of trip right so I am like
working in my gifts I'm like this is
what I was created to do and so as we're
planning the trip I mean I'm on my
laptop every night uh researching
looking at the looking at the hotel
figuring out okay which way should we
get to the park do you take the tram
should we walk the buses I mean I'm
making her schedule I mean I am I am all
in even to the point it's embarrassing
but it's true I would go on YouTube and
watch random families and their trips to
Disney
I was like the Winston's like what are
you watching I'm like The Miller's from
Ohio
but I'm like watching their trip I would
watch the roller coasters
I would watch the roller coasters I
would sit there and watch videos of
every roller coaster at Disney World I
measured my girls so I knew what they're
you know how tall they were to figure
out which rides they could go on I mean
this is an all-in thing you gotta
understand all in and so I realized in
my planning that there were two roller
coasters that my middle one Caroline it
was not tall enough to ride but Amelia
our oldest could Space Mountain
yeah I know I was gonna have a Disney
fan here
and Everest so Everest is a pretty
intense roller coaster in Animal Kingdom
so that day came we're in Animal Kingdom
Caroline there's just tears that she
can't ride it and we're showing her the
measurement like sorry so Winston takes
her off and it's me and Amelia and
thankfully my kids love roller coasters
you know girls after their own Mom's
heart I just love it and so we're in the
little queue and you're going through
and and Disney's pretty great I mean
they're pretty creative right so you're
looking around at all the artifacts and
and you're getting to the line and and
Amelia's like oh Mom I just I just want
to get on now and I'm like I know me too
me too like I just like we're so excited
well there's a girl in front of us I
mean I say girl probably mid to late 20s
and and I see her and she's kind of
doing this and suddenly she turns around
and she just looks at us and she looks
at me and she's like
I was like oh and she looks at a million
she was and she stops and she's to my
seven-year-old and she said
if you can do it I can do it
and Emily was like yeah you can you got
you got this
and I was like you've got this you've
got this so we get to the front you know
you're at the gates and the people get
off the coaster you get on you buckle up
I'm buckling Amelia making sure she's
all good
and it begins and if you've been on that
one specific roller coaster it kind of
just it's kind of nice at first you kind
of go around the bend and you kind of go
up a little Hill and it's like oh and
you're okay and then all of a sudden
it's like oh
right and it's like the classic roller
coaster Mountain that everyone's on and
we're going up and and it's to the point
that I'm like I'm a full grown adult who
pays taxes like I'm I'm a human and an
adult a grown-up a mom but you start
like questioning every life decision
that you've made into this point
they're going up and I'm like okay this
is gonna be good and I hear from right
in front of us
the girl in line
scream at the top of her lungs get me
and Amelia looks at me she's like I
can't wait I was like I know
and then you go to the top and it begins
but I will say that little Tipping Point
right there in life was us and the stock
market last year
where everyone is questioning every life
decision you've made to this point and
and with this coaster you know the
roller coaster ride everyone enters the
market even differently right some
people are excited and enthusiastic
maybe a little
um naive like Amelia my seven year old
you know just jumping right in some
people are very fearful very cautious uh
you know everyone kind of enters
differently but let me tell you it's a
ride it's a ride and when it comes to
Building Wealth the market you guys
George said it earlier but it's one of
the most consistent ways to build wealth
over time
but man
it's a ride so you gotta hang on and you
have to stay on the ride and the problem
is is that fear can take over can't it
right you're watching the news you're
you're reading posts on Facebook and
you're kind of thinking oh my gosh am I
crazy you know is this the right thing
and you start questioning everything and
fear can just take over
so I want to walk through how do we face
our fears when it comes to the market
because the truth is if we want to build
wealth it really is one of the best ways
one of the most effective ways to build
wealth over time so the first way to
kind of face your fear of the market is
to face the fear it's just simply that
and what's hard is when you're watching
the news I feel like they want you to be
scared of everything right they're like
the jobs report the housing market the
stock market oh my gosh is everything
and you're kind of thinking I think the
world's gonna end right you get to this
point and you're so fearful
and when your fear is not specific and
it's just general you can be paralyzed
by it so when it comes to being fearful
of the market or from the economy be
very specific what am I afraid of
am I afraid because we're living
paycheck to paycheck and it's terrible
right am I afraid because inflation I'm
feeling it am I afraid because I
genuinely was gonna retire this year and
looking at my 401k I may not be able to
are you fearful of of the job market
because your company is laying off
people right like be very specific about
your fear don't let it be this general
idea that I'm scared of the economy be
very specific and then control what you
can control we have said that phrase a
thousand billion times it feels like
over the last two years here at Ramsey
but that's the truth control what you
can control which means there's not a
lot of things in life that we can
control
the older I get
and the more therapy I do the more I
realize that's true right there's not a
lot that we can control but with our
money we can control our income when it
hits our bank account we get to make
decisions right we get to decide am I
going to spend it am I going to pay off
debt am I going to invest what am I
going to do with that if you are in the
market you have control to say am I
going to stop investing am I going to
continue to invest am I going to pull
money out you have options there so so
figuring out what you can control is so
so key so facing your fear head-on
number two overcome your fear with facts
this is going to help you so we're gonna
get a little nerdy here this is like
stock market 101 are you ready
okay let's just talk about the stock
market what is the stock market
the stock market is a market of stocks
which are tiny pieces of ownership and
public companies that you and I get to
buy into they're bought and sold that
those shares and so we get to be
investors everyday people like you and I
get to be investors in the economy and
that's amazing that's what the stock
market really is
and what happens with the stock market
is you can watch it and you can see okay
the activity and the perceived values of
those shares go up and down based on
really how people are feeling in the
world
it's that okay so when people are
feeling great and they're like oh yeah
life is awesome we're we're shopping
we're buying stuff for our kids we're
going on vacation we're going out to eat
we're buying new cars we buy like we are
just spending and doing great well guess
what when you spend money to companies
the value of those companies go up so
the the values the perceived values go
up and everything's great
but
when fear comes in uncertain times
maybe a pandemic
maybe a war maybe an election season
maybe a bad jobs report comes out but
something happens and everyone's like
ooh this feels unstable so I'm going to
contract and not spend as much I'm going
to hold my money and we're going to be a
little bit more conservative because we
don't know what's going on well when
people are not out spending money the
values of those companies perceive value
kind of goes down so you see that
happening right I mean it is it is a
living
organism is what it feels like right the
stock market I mean it is a living
breathing thing and you can watch it
there's even channels you know on cable
news that you can turn on and literally
watch in real time the mar and what and
what it's doing like it's just it's wild
and so what's happened recently is yeah
I mean we're we're feeling that downturn
but you go back a few years you guys
um you know there's a thing covid-19
so you go back to March of 2020 which
feels like 20 years ago doesn't it
go back to March of 2020 okay the
markets fell 9.5 percent you guys in one
day it was the worst day for the market
since Black Monday
in 1987. okay so it
it tanked March of 2020 right I mean
it's when covet hit everything right
you're feeling it so what's Wild is when
you watch the market and you look you
see okay yeah I dove and everyone kind
of freaked out and panicked well August
of that year a few months later it
returned
and then if you remember in 2021 we
actually ended 2021
uh breaking records the s p broke a
record I mean it just it it was great
2021 was was insane for the market and
then Here Comes 2022 right and it goes
back down so again it's it's this
feeling of up and down but what I want
to encourage you where we're at right
now
if you're looking at your mutual funds
if you see your 401k if you're in the
market you know it's not great
it's not great Winston night we have a
mutual fund and he but this was just I
mean I think it was last week
and he was like oh look at this and I
looked I was like oh I don't know I
don't want to see I don't want to see it
I don't want to see it because it is
it's been really tough it's been really
really hard
but here's the deal
when the market goes down like that you
guys that is the time to continue to
invest invest consistently because it's
on sale that's what happens it's on sale
what a thousand dollars would have
bought you in 2021 how many shares right
here well in 2022 you get to buy a whole
lot more for the same amount of money
and here's the beautiful thing when
you're buying it at the bottom as it
continues to go up which I believe it
will I believe in the American economy
enough to believe that it will go up
you'll watch it you'll watch it go back
up and you then if you're in the market
and you're on baby step four you get to
build out you get to build that value
back and you get that that money you get
to watch your money grow with it when
people are fearful and they don't want
to invest they try to jump in when it's
getting good and they've missed all that
gross okay so in the investing
consistently you guys is so so key and
again 2022 or yeah I look back last year
and I'm like you know on the Everest
ride the roller coaster million I run
there's a apart if you've been on it and
you get to this dead end
and it's like these fake tracks that go
nowhere and you're like what do we do
where do we go oh we're going backwards
and you go backwards into this dark
tunnel and you're like I have no idea
what's going on in life right now you
know that's that's kind of what it felt
like but staying on the roller coaster
and not jumping off is what keeps you
safe
and staying on it and riding it out okay
so I mentioned the S P 500
um and George has been talking about the
market as well so when you look at
something like that again there's these
words that are thrown out
in this in this topic uh things like the
S P 500 or the Dow Jones and it's like
what is this well I I like looking at
the S P 500 because
basically what is it's a it's a stock
index and so it's basically a measuring
stick that shows how the overall economy
is doing because it's the S P 500 which
means it's the 500 largest publicly
traded companies is what the S P 500 is
watching so you get a good picture
because what makes up that are are
companies like Delta Hershey's uh Home
Depot American Airlines Netflix Nike
my favorites targets the black hole of
goodness I mean it's just great right so
it's these large companies that you're
watching and when you look at the
history of the markets because that's
also important to know okay if we're in
it and we're not we're in a fearful time
and it doesn't look good what does
history show us well history shows us
that the annual the average annual
return since 1928 through 2021 was 11.82
percent
okay that that was the average and what
I like to look at that is I like to see
the overall big perspective of the
market because again if you're in it
it's scary right now it's not fun
but that's because we have a
short-sighted view if we're just looking
at the presence that's why backing up
and and seeing the pattern of what it's
doing is really important to your wealth
building and I love patterns in life
because when you when you know that
something is kind of predictable you're
like okay that gives you a little bit of
safety a little bit of Peace uh our
youngest is three and we tried potty
training like two months ago and it was
just a disaster boys I don't know what
this thing is I was like y'all y'all are
crazy potty training a boy is so hard so
I just gave up I'm just lazy and I'm
like you'll figure it out it's fine
we'll find it
so I can tell you it's kind of gross
your parents will understand but during
his nap when I go get him up at 3 30
there's a pattern that he poops every
nap I walk in and it stinks his room
it's predictable I know I'm not shocked
I'm prepared and I know the pattern
right if you go to Chick-fil-A you can
be pretty sure that your order is going
to be right
Jesus chicken always just proves well
right
so there's a pattern that you can count
on so patterns are really helpful and
when we're looking at the market seeing
patterns can give us peace so let's just
do a little example let's just look to
see the last five years when it comes to
the S P 500 just to see this graph okay
so 2018 so you're seeing it up right
2021 we talked about was a really great
time and then it went down okay and then
let's zoom out again 10 years
okay so you're standing like yeah yeah
see that roller coaster ride 30 years
up down and I see that the 2008 right
there all the way right the Great
Recession all of that okay and then
let's go let's go 100 years
okay so that's that's the market right
up here is where we are and what I when
I look at this and for Wills building to
know what how do I want to build wealth
to me I look at it I'm like there's a
pattern right there's a trajectory of it
going up yes it does this and it's
insane and it's nuts but overall you can
see that pattern that it continues to go
up and so that's why I have confidence I
do I still have confidence in the market
and that's why we're still investing and
Building Wealth again this is such a a
huge key and and the reality is too
where the s p is today as we're doing
this live stream is higher than where it
was in 2019.
pre-covet okay so again it feels insane
it feels like oh my gosh it's up and
down but really when you look at the
numbers it gives you peace so
when it comes to Building Wealth we want
to face our fears we want to get the
facts learn some new stuff hopefully to
have some peace and safety with our
building Wells and then the third thing
of overcoming is just to keep investing
I'm telling you guys
consistent investing is what is going to
help you build wealth the survey that we
did with net worth millionaires found
that investment consistency was the
second most important factor to Building
Wealth is what they would say the first
was Financial discipline
and what's fascinating too is they they
studied the net worth Millionaires and
then they studied the general public the
general public said investing
consistency was the seventh most
important thing to do to build wealth so
millionaires
general public right we're gonna we're
gonna go over here investing
consistently is so key so if you are out
of debt
if you have a fully funded emergency
fund
funding your retirement that 15 of your
income into retirement you guys is still
important even in a down economy
keep at it and if you're a first time
investor maybe you're at the point that
you are on baby step four you've fully
funded your emergency fund you're on
this journey and you're a little bit gun
shy get in get in get in and do it
because over time that is what's going
to help you build wealth so so how do
you invest though in a down economy
because a lot of people are asking that
okay so I want to invest so so what does
that look like number one rule diversify
don't go single stocks don't put all
your eggs in one basket diversify mutual
funds within your 401k is great
spreading your money around I know it
sounds boring and it's not exciting you
guys but again look at the pattern look
at the consistency and do what what what
has a rate of return that we know of
okay so mutual funds is a great place
and then number two you write it out
write it out
continue continue to invest again even
if it's down uh Warren Buffett has a
great quote and he said
be fearful when others are greedy and be
greedy when others are fearful
greedy I don't really like that word
it's not a great word but I like the
idea because you were last year crypto
was like the big thing cryptocurrency
everyone's like oh yeah get the Bitcoin
on this so you're gonna make so much
money you're gonna make so much money
there's so much hype around crypto and
there's a little bit of that greed of
like getting quick yeah get rich quick
when they're when that stuff is
happening you guys be a little fearful
right get back and be like let's see how
this plays out hasn't played out great
for them
and then when people are fearful right
now they're freaked out they're pulling
their money out they're stop investing
they're freaking out that's when you
know to jump in and so don't freak out
don't jump off the ride continue to
invest and again that perspective the
long-term perspective is going to help
it really is so facing your fear getting
the facts keep investing and just know
this is for the long term this is for
the long term and it's hard to have that
perspective sometimes you know even with
my three kids we're like in the thick of
it they're three five and seven and it's
it's just a lot you know you're just
like wow there's a lot of humans in our
home it's what it feels like
and you'll you know you'll meet these
people at the grocery store great
intentions but they're like oh I just
sent my youngest to college
enjoy every second and I'm like
are you changing diapers at 3 30 every
day are you no no you're not and I'll be
honest I'm like okay I know that I know
it's true you know the days are long but
the years are short you know it's on a
coffee mug you know I I get it up here
but some days I'm like yeah no I want
them like changing their own clothes and
stuff like we want to we want to keep
moving along right
and so I don't have that perspective I'm
in the thick of it and so that's how the
market is again remember having step
back and have that big perspective
and so when Amelia and I when we ended
the Everest ride uh they they brought us
down you know you get out and it's like
turn the gates open and people kind of
clap or they're laughing all this and we
get out and Amelia was like I want to do
it again mom I want to do it again I'm
like we're not standing in that line
again and we're not standing in that
light again and so we're walking out and
the girl in front of us I remember she
looked back at us and she goes oh
well wasn't as terrible as I thought
and I thought you know what I I think 65
year old Rachel is going to say that
about her investing
that was a ride that was a ride there
were some scary moments but you know
what ah just it wasn't as bad as I
thought that's my prayer so again you
guys this whole Building Wealth idea
when it comes to investing it's boring
it's not exciting like George said I I
wish I had this like fun flashy formula
that no one's ever heard of
but it's the consistent investing that's
really going to help you build wealth
and you build wealth not just to stock
up money and you know keep it all right
like there is a true intention of your
why why are you doing this
changing your family tree being generous
I mean there's amazing stuff that money
can do money is a tool to create a life
that you love and Building Wealth does
that in scale so thank you guys so much
I want to welcome back to the stage my
dad Dave at Ramsey
thank you
all right give it up for Rachel and
George one more time
[Applause]
well there are a lot of lessons
from what we've all walked through as a
culture
from uh the quarantine and the coveted
process and then the things and the
issues following but for sure regardless
of what side of some of those issues you
sit on or stand on I think we can all
agree one thing we have learned is that
people humans need other humans it is
not good for men to be alone
isolation disconnection
is what Hermits do
eccentric people do people that have
mental illness
do that
if you want to avoid those things you
connect
and the problem is you're connecting
with people because there's like going
to church there's a problem there's
people there they screw the thing up you
know it's like it's going to be good
then there were people there
but it is how life works best
it is not good that man be alone
how many of you guys have been through
in this room have been through Financial
Peace University that George and Rachel
talked about wow good gosh in this room
it's about 30 or 40 percent that's
pretty cool so that means in this room
and watching all across America the two
or three hundred thousand of you
watching that there's really three kinds
of folks at that on that subject there's
ones that have been through Financial
Peace University and learned it and
maybe know someone else that needs it
there's someone who's never been through
it and oh my goodness 10 million folks
have been through this it's something
you need to look at it changes
everything it's the plan the
step-by-step process The Proven way of
accomplishing these goals we've been
talking about tonight
and of course there's a third type the
one that went through an attribution
needs to do it again
that would be me when I graduated from
college I was the portion of the class
that allowed the top half to be possible
um yeah I graduated thank you Lottie and
so um
so I I if that's you I understand
completely uh but I tell you what this
process that we've honed in and of 10
million folks have gone through the
class now and millions and millions of
millionaires and now generationally
because we've been doing it so long
we're now meeting even third Generations
that are taking this material this God's
ways of handling money Grandma's Common
Sense the things we've been talking
about tonight and applying them and
we're really really seeing the results
it's um nine lessons long and so it
takes nine weeks if you do one lesson a
week that's how we've always done it
traditionally and that works best really
you need to kind of absorb this and keep
going through it you don't do one lesson
and nine years later do another lesson
you do them all in a row right and uh
but it teaches you the things you were
told about money or that you weren't
told about money see a lot of people
grew up in a household where their
parents didn't talk about sex or money
and then they were surprised to find out
they had both
and so this is the place where you you
know you say this is how it works this
is the class we all should have been
taught
but have not been taught that's what it
amounts to our team's been working
really hard we have a new addition out
just came out last year it involves
Rachel teaching some of the classes yay
George teaching some of the classes Dr
John deloney's in there I'm still
anchoring the deal running up and down
the stage with my bald head yelling and
flapping my arms but um you will leave
motivated and you will leave with
knowledge that you didn't have before
and you will have to decide whether you
agree with it or not I will not leave
you the option of being unclear
uh you'll know exactly what you're
supposed to do and you will then choose
if you're going to do it or not because
we can show you how to do this stuff
so when I first started teaching it I
taught it with an overhead projector and
a bad suit
there are 30 people in the room and it
was 526 dollars to go through and we'd
be in there for 26 weeks by God you were
going to learn it you know it was like
boot camp you know what I'm saying
people left crying every night you know
it was like hardcore I'll do it Dave
just don't you don't give me the
scissors I'll cut up my own credit cards
you know it's like uh but nowadays it's
a lot more sophisticated and a lot nicer
and you got Rachel she's a lot nicer
than I am so I'm
so tonight we're going to do something
we've never done this is pretty cool
we're going to bundle a bunch of things
together and give the best deal we've
ever done in our lives
um because we really sense that there's
a timing thing right now in this culture
the Bible says be not conformed to this
world
but be transformed
don't be like those guys be transformed
by the renewing
of your mind you gotta have new stuff in
your brain to be something you've never
been before to do something you've never
done before to believe something you've
never believed before and I'm the same
way I have to constantly do this I'm
constantly reading I've read three books
this week I was off goofing off since
Christmas and been reading like crazy I
love it it's just one of my favorite
things in the world because it fires me
up man it's amazing so we're gonna do a
one-on-one coaching session when you buy
Financial Peace University tonight a
one-on-one coaching session you'll get
to sit talk to over the phone one of our
coaches and get into detail on your
Investments on your debt on you know
getting your spouse on board how do I do
the budget I don't understand in my
situation how to do it we're going to
walk you through the little details
because it gets kind of antsy it gets
kind of nerdy in there and we're going
to walk you through it with one-on-one
and
we're going to give daily coaching calls
group coaching calls for a year
you can jump in up to once a day when
group coaching calls and there'll be
subjects like investing or budgeting or
side hustles for extra money or whatever
you can jump in and every day get a hold
of a human being because people need
people you need the connection and we've
scaled this we've got the ability to do
it now and I'm really excited about this
because this is the magic it's not the
information if information had changed
your life you already would already done
this because the math is sixth grade
listen to Mathis this is not calculus
it's not trigonometry you don't have to
know the Pythagorean theorem to do this
I mean you live on less than you make
this is a second grade activity you know
but we have to have the situation and
the people around us to do it and that's
why this coaching and this group
coaching element is so so important
Financial Peace University of course the
nine week class the average person in
all the years we've been doing this has
a in the first 90 days as an 8 000
turnaround fifty three hundred dollars
in debt paid off 2700 saved
it's an eight thousand dollar change in
the first 90 days because you get into
it and you're game on and you're not
thinking about nothing else you know
like when you look at uh when you look
at green cars all sudden you see green
cars everywhere you know when you start
doing this stuff you're going to find
out there's people everywhere getting
out of debt you're like I thought I was
I thought nothing nobody there's a lot
of people doing this
it's really a thing you know it's moving
out there so it's 79 if you just want to
go through the class that's a normal
price on it normal price on every dollar
premium which is the budgeting app you
can do it for free but if you want to
connect to your bank it's 60 bucks a
year okay so that's another 60 bucks to
play we're gonna throw in the every
dollar premium so one-on-one coaching
group coaching Financial Peace
University every dollar premium all
together all of that added up it is uh
500 579 dollar value if you added it all
up and tonight it's 69 dollars
yeah
that's
it is the best deal I've ever put on a
national stage like this ever since I've
been doing this I mean we've sold it for
199 we've sold it for 226. we sold it
for 526 I told you that when I started
because that was a little bit analog to
say the least uh the Al Gore hadn't
invented the internet at that point and
so
um but the uh that's an old joke but uh
still works
the uh uh you know I mean it's that old
I've been doing this stuff a long time
and I've gotten to see the results and I
still get the letters and I still meet
people who's say this stuff saved my
marriage and I'm like hey the sex class
was down the hall you know but what we
teach people to do is connect and
communicate and have shared goals and
communicate on their values on why and
why are we doing this why are why would
we ever sell our car well because it's
killing us
because all we use fight about money and
every time I go to the grocery store I'm
I have a freaking panic attack but I'll
go to F-150
you know it's like it's out of control
y'all and so you gotta confront the
brutal facts right do the the Stockdale
Paradox and have faith that if I
confront the brutal facts the end of the
story is going to be good
that's the faith part and you step into
that and you go if I plant corn there's
a high likelihood corn is going to grow
if I plant nothing there's a high
likelihood of a mud puddle when it rains
and so if I do nothing I'm going to keep
if I keep doing what I've been doing I'm
gonna keep getting what I've been
getting it's the definition of insanity
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result and so we
all know this stuff sometimes we need
someone to come alongside us and love us
care about us we do we care about you
and kick in the butt because we love you
you know I'm gonna pop you up beside the
head straighten up you know because I
love you because I need to do it but I
want you to win man I want you to do
this stuff and so the other thing we're
going to do is if you want to do two of
these bundles
meaning you're going to go through it or
you're going to want to give away two of
them that's fine either way uh we're
gonna do it for 99 and we're gonna mail
you a copy of The Total Money the baby
steps a millionaire is my latest number
one bestseller how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
and this is the whole study of
millionaires that we did and the results
that came from it and we're going to
show you from a Christian perspective
from a uh
from a factual academic perspective from
a math perspective and from case study
perspective and from 30 years of
experience perspective exactly why
people become millionaires in America
today and hint spoiler alert they didn't
inherit their money
that's the greatest lie the Socialists
have ever spread
and that's just it's just a lie it's a
statistical lie it's just not the truth
it's not like agree with you I don't
care you're wrong
you know that's the point I mean we've
got data to prove this this is proven it
is not in question anymore so we can
show you how to do this stuff now one of
the beautiful things about this is I get
to meet people as I go all around the
country and I want to introduce you to
two of my friends they're absolutely
incredible George and Lisa and they are
which you can do by the way if you want
to do this 99 or you want to do the 69
you can just click on the QR code those
of you watching at home you can get that
little phone thing out to that QR code
and the cool the QR code came back
because of covet it almost died and now
the QR codes everywhere again you know
it's like you had to do it for your
menus so now you do it for everything
you know it's like but anyway it's live
again who knew and um but it's it's
working so do the QR code and that'll
get you signed up or you can go to
Ramsey solution or ramsesolutions.com
FPU the 69.99 deal is there those of you
in the room will have it here in the
building for you after we're done and be
able to sign books for you and all that
kind of stuff so uh you know just make
sure that that's what we're doing but I
want to introduce you to George and Lisa
they're absolutely incredible George's
uh worked for the water department the
water treatment company there in Los
Angeles you work one job is basically
his whole life we're not he worked at
one place his whole life worked several
jobs working his way up through the
thing and just saving in this 401k and
uh they ran into us about 2017.
so about what five six years ago now and
they were most of their way into their
millionaire process and then when they
took Financial Peace University it just
catapulted them the rest of the way
through but it's still just this
incredible sweet couple and just a
powerful story so watch my friends
George and Lisa
I told my wife you know I'm thinking
about retiring I've run the numbers see
what she goes well if you want to you
think you're ready I go yeah oh and we
calculate this you know let's check out
your 401K how much is in there and I
told him I think we're a millionaire I
didn't believe her
I work for a water treatment company I
was there for 40 years and I started as
a custodian you know 18 year old kid
fresh out of high school as I'm there
working and I see that there's other
jobs and I took some supervisory classes
at the junior college and I put in for
the jobs the interview prepared myself
and and I actually got the job
we had a 401k and so I started just two
percent you know small and then over
time little by little every time I got a
raise I started increasing it till I
maxed it out to the most that I could
and I don't want to say that everything
was peaches and roses and yes we made
mistakes along the way but in spite of
those the goal was to pay off our house
and be there free
if you think it can't happen or it won't
happen it probably won't so you gotta
get out of that way of thinking and just
say I want to try something different it
wasn't for that I probably would have
stayed at custodian I mean it sounds so
simple but everything you do can just
take you another step forward if you're
intentional about saving if you try to
say I'm going to be a millionaire
tomorrow then it's like okay that's why
they call it baby steps when you do one
step at a time you see progress
[Music]
from custodian to maintenance worker
station mechanic instrument technician
to supervisor now I'm worth 1.1 million
if I can do it you can do it
well there's two new faces here on the
stage with us right here is best-selling
author and host of the Ken Coleman Show
Ken Coleman
[Applause]
and then next to him is best-selling
author host of the Dr John deloney show
Dr John deloney
foreign
so every year people come out with their
predictions of trends that are going to
be happening in the upcoming year so
people what people people experts oh
okay
but you there's a lot of articles that
come out and they're like oh hey here's
your trends that you're possibly going
to see and that's in money that's in
health all the things so we thought it'd
be fun to pick out a few of the trends
that we've heard about and kind of talk
through and think okay is this
legitimate do we think we're really
going to see this in 2023
it's all starts off please so the the uh
Trend that I saw that I just related to
and you guys appreciate that because of
my Disney story is a thing that people
are predicting that Revenge travel
is going to be at an all-time high
Revenge travel explain that Revenge
travel yeah I don't know what this is so
Revenge travel there's William Neeson
and taking what's happening
it's because that people were not able
to travel for you know two years and now
they have this pent up tension like we
want to get out we want to get out we
don't care what it costs we're going to
travel we're going to see the world
we're going to take our families and
more than ever they're saying the travel
industry is going to be well they got
time because they quit their job
I think it's going to be a thing though
I mean already yeah you already can't
get a reservation places well I'm
booking travel right now and I'm like
number one it's so expensive it's so not
just the airlines but the hotels
everything I'm like it's so expensive
right now that was the worst time to
stay home here's the thing add up how
much you spend just to live in your
house and I'm like that's a hotel stay I
enjoy it why go anywhere you have you
have one of thank you oh no wait a
second wait a second no no no don't clap
for him like he's he's neurotic it's all
Neurosis he's not okay
that went well that's my that's my
Trends and I think you're gonna see it
so when you guys start to see travel go
crazy you're gonna say Rachel Cruz was
right okay George what's your trip wow
okay so the trend we're seeing right now
is Sky High interest rates with credit
cards we're seeing with car loans we're
seeing it in the housing market and so
because of that we're going to see a
huge spike in Consumer Debt which means
people will turn to terrible options
like buy now pay later so I think we're
going to see a huge Spike especially
with younger Generations turning to buy
now pay later where they put everything
on four payments right what are those
companies called the the fintech company
after Florida after pay
um they're so cute that they think they
invented this I found a newspaper the
other day we were cleaning out our house
we're moving when Nixon resigned
well
1972 or four or something like that I'll
keep those newspapers I'm old I was I
was a kid when it happened shut up but
um but anyway I had the newspaper I
still kept it because it's a Keepsake
and but I was I got to thumbing through
the classifieds and the the you know the
car ads are hilarious the pinto is for
sale right you know the world's worst
car ever made except possibly some of
those American Motors Gremlins but the
uh um you know so I found that stuff but
also it's still eight three easy
payments oh yeah like freaking klarner
because it's on your iPhone invented it
that's crap well here's the craziest
part they they're getting these young
Generations made it new it's like
layaway right I remember yeah layaway
when I was but lay away they don't
penalize you this crap here's how stupid
these people are they're financing a
pizza
four payments on a pizza
and you add it to your tab right I was
buying a t-shirt with a funny saying on
it and they offered me payments
underneath right y'all seen it George
though but I think sure I feel like
there's been stuff out no now that those
companies actually are losing value like
they're not doing it well well there's
more competition in that space and so
now it's a fight for the market share
with the retailers yeah they're ripping
the consumer a new one for sure and
there's all kinds of traps right they
promised the zero percent on your four
payments but there's all kinds of fees
and it triggers interest but here's the
big kicker klarna brags to retailers
that if they use their their uh program
consumers will spend up to 45 percent
more
so I'm less worried about the fees I'm
more worried about a generation that's
broke because they spent 45 percent more
because you don't feel it when it's over
four payments you want fries with your
t-shirt it's insane so that's my Trend
there you go take it or leave it I'll
tell you yeah yeah I hear you I hear you
okay yeah you know so we've had a couple
things that are leading to this trend
over the last several years one is
obviously the skyrocketing cost of
college tuition in our borrowed future
documentary we really exposed that in a
powerful way so that's been happening
for some time right decades and it just
keeps getting more and more expensive
well then the pandemic hits and all
these colleges and universities or most
sending everybody home but the tuition
is the same so now the kids and the
parents who've kind of thought well this
is the golden ticket to success they
start to question the ROI the return on
investment so that's happening okay and
then you've got Corporate America over
the last decade
they're beginning to see that kids are
coming out of colleges and universities
and they're really not qualified to do
the job and they're having to train them
anyway then so that so that's that's
kind of one storm altogether then this
other storm that's happening uh that's
on the horizon and it's coming fast is
is that we've got four million less
people in the workforce after the
pandemic so they just chose optional
retirement but the pandemic spun off
four million new jobs and that's why we
have if you watch the news you're seeing
stuff you hear talk about the labor
shortage all right we're going to get an
egghead of nerdy but what that means is
that companies are desperate for people
and they're looking for people the great
resignation has started to happen Dave
talked about that earlier tonight the
the the the crazy numbers of people that
have just switched jobs so all this
turnover plus a shortage of people has
companies going you know what we're
going to change the old school way of
thinking that said if you don't have a
college degree no need to apply
and that is changing rapidly give you a
real example big companies like Delta
the largest airline in the world over 50
of their jobs don't require a college
degree that's a big shift IBM big blue
we're talking one of the gold standard
technology companies is now have about
40 to 50 percent of their jobs not
requiring a degree and their CEO
recently told Fortune Magazine this and
and this is why the trend is happening
he said we did an internal study and we
found that our employees that had no
degree performed just
as well as our people with phds now on
the count of three I want us to all
right John right hashtag no no no no but
seriously on the count of three I want
us to all say duh one two three
yeah really the small business has known
this for years yes it's not ever hired I
got 1100 people working here I've never
hired somebody because of where they
went to school and I've never not hired
them because I didn't have a degree I
didn't hire them because I didn't think
they could do the job
sure but there are fields that you have
to absolutely okay yeah not questioning
it what I've seen you're going to do
accounting that you've got an account so
it's probably a good idea like my brain
surgeon like yeah I I got this bro I got
this you're like watch a YouTube video
watch the Youtube video stayed the
Holiday Inn last night yeah right
although we never asked him where he got
to disagree so here's here's the payoff
what does that mean for you all and why
do I bring this trend up it is leveling
the playing field if you don't have a
degree or you don't have a fancy degree
no more whining no degree required go
get you some money it is changing the
game
changing the game and as a result of
that the mini Trend the mini Trend I'm
sorry I'm fired up I've been a lot of
Trends I've been waiting for four hours
all right I got to say something all
right listen here's the deal and what's
really exciting is the trades are
exploding you're going to see more
people moving to the trades you're going
to see white collar workers I took a
call today on the Ken Coleman show the
guy wants to walk away from a white
collar job and get into the trades to
become a small businessman that's
America that's good that's exciting
it makes our friend Mike Rowe really
excited
can you follow that up John
no
I think I'm gonna go a little more bold
I think in
um
I think in 2023
I just I'm just I think I think the
Macarena returns as the dance to do
oh no way
no I I think
right John it feels right
I think Tick Tock could do it yeah
single-handedly are you willing to start
it are you willing to start it on
Instagram reels tonight I can't move
here's the thing when my when my arms
move my hips freeze and then when my
hips move people call the cops it's a
whole thing so I'm just gonna put out
here's what I think I think that um this
is good yeah so
I uh
I'm a direct beneficiary of therapy and
counseling it's changed my life it saved
my life
um there was a season when I had a close
friend who was a medical doctor and he
walked me through he's in medication say
it was transformative okay so I say all
that up front to say this
um if you step back and look at I'll
just say the United States we've got
more people millions and millions and
millions of people in counseling we have
millions and millions and millions of
people medicated
and the problems of anxiety and
depression continue to escalate
when when they discovered penicillin
death from infections fell off the table
that solved that problem what we are
trying to do we're throwing at anxiety
with Throne into pressure we're throwing
at this chaos isn't it's holding it at
Bay it's giving people different roads
and opportunities the problems continue
to escalate and I think we have a
culture that is completely
um the engine that drives the culture is
you might die tomorrow you might die you
might die you might die you might die
you might die and so I think uh my
prediction for for this year is I think
we've got another six to nine months of
continued mental health challenges until
we finally have this
terrifying it's all coming down
recession or we have something that we
all experience together
and then we're going to go to sleep and
we're going to wake up and the sun will
have come out and we'll go huh
I'm a little bit stronger than I thought
or we're going to get laid off and I'm
just going to say I'm going to follow
can't you say I'm just going to go I'm
gonna go this way this time and I'm
going to find a new job and I'm going to
realize I'm a lot stronger than it was
I'm a lot tougher than I was I had more
people in my corner than I ever imagined
and that's resilience and that's when
our minds start to go oh you're driving
now I don't need to set these alarms all
anxiety is an alarm system right we
don't have to ring the alarms off the
hook anymore because you're back in the
driver's seat and I think um and I'll
pitch you here Dave I think the mice
would you call it a mini mini prediction
um
right as I left the university setting
to come uh be a be a YouTuber my my
students were starting this thing
quietly and they would go out to eat
together or they'd go grab drinks and
nachos or whatever and they would all
stack up their cell phones in the first
person to grab it had to pay for the
meal
and it was leaving leave it to college
kids leave it to the younger generations
to both
amplify the current culture but to also
say I'm not living like that and so I I
think we are rounding a corner that
um people are gonna have to start
looking at each other can I ask you a
question yeah yeah
I'm sitting here just observing I've got
three teens and just kind of observing
everything that we observe I I when you
say that that is incredibly hopeful but
I'm just I've never asked you this
the fear-mongering that we see on
whatever your favorite News website is
or whatever Twitter account you follow I
mean it is just negative negative never
we've never had more news we've never
had more access to information
how much is that playing into this
onslaught of anxiety that we're just
constantly being told that the world is
falling apart our we're running on
Ancient technology right that's designed
to tell us there's a bear at the front
of a cave
and maybe in the course of your lifetime
there would be two or three bears and it
would say fight that bear or run from
that bear or play dead and that bear
will gnaw off one of your legs and drag
you out under a pile of leaves and then
you can live to fight another day right
that's it that's hoping the bearer just
lick you and run away you went really
deep without it so
now like I said our Cur the engine that
drives our culture is fear and so
they're telling you there's a there's a
there's a bear in your toothpage you
know what's in that toothpaste it's
going to kill your teeth they're gonna
fall on your head and then you quit
brushing your teeth it's like oh bad
breath is going to lead to heart disease
dead and then it's like oh you wear
shoes you should be barefoot oh you wear
Barefoot your knees are going to fall
there are bears everywhere and our
brains are just going this is and it's
just fried it's like we're putting our
study out every day that contradicts the
study from the day before that's right
that's right that's why we drink America
right now I'm just kidding kids you know
what I've decided John that I don't care
what they come up with I'm eating bacon
all day all day all day that's America
forever forever hey here's here's what
I'm
laughs
hey here's why I'm hopeful I hope it's
okay to share this the the the number
um a year ago or two years ago right
before I took this job of my buddy I I
called my buddy he was on the board at
Apple and Google he was a smart guy he's
a brilliant lovely guy and I said hey
what's the book that hasn't been written
yet like there's so much noise out in
the world and before I I leave what I
know and take this other job what's a
book you would like to read and he said
well I've read all the studies that say
Technology's killing my family so I took
away all the screens and now me and my
three daughters are just sitting here in
the living room staring at each other
what do I do now and I go oh I just talk
to him and he goes okay I'll just talk
to him and he is like oh what I do now
and so we created these little questions
for humans which is a deck of cards with
questions that are designed to get you
past the first and second layer
it became we sold over a million dollars
worth of cards they have taken off in a
Banana's way and here's why there's
nothing sophisticated about these things
I assure you you should be in some of
the planning meetings they get really
dark right
but people have an excuse and they talk
to their kids or they talk to their
grandkids or they talk to their husband
or wife not just about what Billy did at
school and what's all going on our
retirement's down but
what's the story from middle school that
you've never told me and they I didn't
so it was one time at band camp exactly
so I think that bacon involved people
are experiencing human connection and I
I'm I'm just convinced that people are
going to say I want to choose a
non-anxious life and that was a culture
we'll we'll make a turn good work
and Dave that kind of leads into I mean
into your Trend exactly and I understand
in all fairness we spend so much time
together that and we are sitting on the
show together three hours a day
answering questions uh different ones of
us you know these are some of our Ramsay
personalities also Christina Ellis and
Jade warshaw now and uh but we're you
know these ideas I'm learning from
deloney he's learning from me I'm
learning from Ken on what's happening in
the career field you know we're all
bouncing ideas back and forth they teach
me about culture I don't even know what
it is
um uh current culture anyway and so um I
mean get anything past Jerry Rafferty I
have trouble right but the uh um 1980
something but yeah who yeah but uh uh
you know this is the best butter churner
in 1804.
thank you very much John but the uh um
if any of y'all are hiring I'll I would
like to talk to you yeah
it's a great resignation I can think of
the trend of Dave age insults keeps up
that uh John won't be here 2024. it was
a new trend it's a good prediction I'm
cheesy I'm good with that the I but I do
I told a group of Business Leaders at
our entree leadership thing uh almost a
year ago now I said I think I really
sense and I I just my finger on the
pulse of our customers and we deal with
tens of millions of people in a given
week with our different podcasts and
different connectivity points is what
John's saying is right on that there's a
relationship Revolution coming
uh that people are getting sick and
tired of the the benefit of technology
is still there and I'm not saying
technology is evil it's not in and of
itself but the uses of it and what it's
doing to people's sleep patterns what
it's doing to youngsters development
um the what you used to have to do if
you were a 14 year old boy to get a hold
of porn
was you had to go to extraordinary links
and now he walks around with it in his
hand
and in the porn addiction there's a
dirty little secret America I mean it's
the fastest growing addiction out there
we're seeing people's houses lost lives
destroyed Mary just ripped apart it's
fast the fastest growing Addiction in
North America more money requiring young
rewiring the brains to where there's all
kinds of sexual dysfunction in their
head in their marriages later that they
can't get past it's huge and it's just
it's the evil use of this Technologies
technology has good uses it's a
wonderful thing I can look at the
weather and not get hit by a tornado
right it's a good thing but um but but
it's out of control and and we've tried
to use it like a magic wand instead of
connecting to humans the dirty messy
work of loving other people well the
unlovable which we all are at our core
unlovable and someone to love them well
instead we bury our head in someone
else's fantasy and they're real on
Instagram or worse and uh so this it's
breaking it's it's falling apart and
people are realizing it so they're gonna
put it down they're not going to put the
whole thing down so different people are
going to say okay this at least limit
the amount of hours on screen or before
bedtime because messing up your sleep
patterns or whatever it is they're going
to start doing this and we're going to
see a relationship Revolution and what
I'm saying is we're going to realize
Facebook friends aren't
friends
they don't come they won't help you
change your tire at 2am
not one of them will show up
you know and work for home doesn't
work
while you're at home
and online connectivity
isn't
connected
really
I mean if you can't get where you can
look in someone's eyes and sense their
body language and hear the pace of their
voice and you just paused I just heard
you lie and I love you enough and I'm
going to call you out on it I'm going to
call you on your stuff right now because
you're my friend and I'm not putting up
with you acting that way that does not
happen online
but that's a good friend that's a man
walking with a man a woman walking with
a woman and and you know sit down and go
you're getting ready to screw your
marriage up I can see it all over you
you need to stop and that does that you
can't do that you can't love people well
and with these things they're good for
other stuff they're magic wand they'll
put stuff on your porch with one click
but but they won't change your life
people change your life so I see a
relationship Revolution beginning and I
hope it begins in in you know with a
passion starting tonight right now
that's great well I thought I was like
we should all come back in December and
just see if the trends what we thought
of the year right yeah with the TR are
the trends going well one Trends George
that I hope continues to increase what's
this plug here that our podcast George
smart money happy hour boy we didn't
rehearse that one continues on obviously
but as we were talking about this panel
talk about it all the time John's
jealous because he doesn't get invited
to the party that is true he got invited
once and never been never again
no but we were talking about this panel
I was like George we should just send
them fun for one podcast so we have fun
on our podcast those that don't know
we've got this new podcast called smart
money happy hour it's me and Rachel two
friends who happen to be money experts
it's very casual it's funny it's helpful
and part of that at the end we do a
segment called guilty as charged where
our producer tees up a question and if
you're guilty you know you got to share
the story and so I wanted to ask one to
the for the good of the group to end on
a light note and that is
what is the purchase you shamelessly
love that others would find embarrassing
John
I imagine your list is plentiful
I didn't know what you said what
I was too I was too excited about this
new podcast called the smart money happy
hour have you guys heard of it wait what
were you saying it's on the screen John
just look at it I'm not going to repeat
it he's pitching you the question what
is it what is the purchase you
shamelessly love Ken what's the purchase
that others would find embarrassed
honestly was looking for a little bit of
clarification because how do I know that
it's embarrassing we'll tell you oh I'll
tell you we'll tell you yeah I know like
what's the thing yes I'm not ashamed of
this listen to this so I was on the road
we were doing I think we're doing this
event and uh I think in California
I didn't pack I didn't pack any
underwear I didn't and so I had to go to
the nearest place and I liked fancy
there was no fancy and I went to Walmart
and it's it's the best underwear I've
ever worn in my life
and I think it's called like like Dan or
George or something it's incredible this
embarrassing you're right
do what all right I'm all about it
that's what I'm saying I have a I have
other list in my mind like I'm thinking
of seven things that you own that I
think are very one what one is John has
these earbuds that shoot light into his
brain that apparently give him vitamin D
stop you you fell one of us is over six
feet tall that's all I'm saying
hey
don't applaud that
for too long John has thought that being
tall is a personality trait it's not I'm
sorry
and you're actually not that tall it's
just we're short yeah uh I don't think
that's vitamin D John you should
probably check that receipt doctor my
wife told me she my wife told me she's
gonna bury me she goes I'm gonna when
you die I'm gonna bury you and all those
stupid gadgets you had
they're right the only one I really
can't think of anything out of this but
this will embarrass Dave and so this oh
good my answer will embarrass Dave it's
embarrassing before it really irritates
him so enjoy this
uh years ago years ago I mean gee whiz I
don't know Josie's 14 so we we have two
we adopted two boys in an biological
daughter and so we've only been through
pregnancy once and Stacy went through
the whole thing and she brought home one
night uh a full-length body pillow you
know for her to sleep you know to help
make her more comfortable being pregnant
some women are shaking their head you
know what I'm talking about and I
remember when she told me about it I was
like huh
that's an interesting concept and I saw
her sleep with it and I remember going I
really want to try that
and I I have uh you know Dave knows that
I have no calf muscle and I don't paint
my pants on like George but I'm still
wearing skinny jeans and I got room in
them I got the littlest legs you've ever
seen in your life and and and so I have
bony knees and bony ankles and my whole
life I would never really felt
comfortable and in that moment it was a
realization that my knees and ankles
never have to touch
and so she went out of town with her mom
God is my witness and I was there
and I went to bed that night and I saw
her pillow and I went
Amazon delivered and I slept with that
full body pillow and it changed my life
in 14 years straight she bought me one
and I still sleep with the body pillow
you're right you're so brave can between
that and you eating bacon you're the
most courageous guy I know thank you
your honesty well I knew that Dave would
be embarrassed and I felt like that
qualified but by the way don't knock it
until you've tried it
my spine is straight
my knees are perfectly apart oh by the
way it's long enough that my elbows goes
well I get all the way to the elbows
enough already enough bacon breath
enough really our live stream is tuned
out Ken they're done we got to keep
going I don't think I I I'm really
trying to think I have a lot I have a
light bulb in one of our lamps that has
an app to it that changes color that's
embarrassing to you I don't know maybe
wow a Tesla an electric car that's
embarrassing to him there we go Dave
hates electric cars Rachel's Tesla
something she's Shameless he loves that
others would find embarrassing you would
never be caught dead in it he's like
it's a battery with wheels I'm like I'm
not paying for gas
I know I am you plug in out here I know
I know a day's pain
[Applause]
is paying these electric cars all
plugged in free like and I know that
Dave's paying for their gas and I just
go ah yes I love it got him
all right I'm gonna go for me I'm gonna
go motion sensor toilet night light
if you know you know here's the here's
the sales pitch it's 3am you're going to
the bathroom you don't want to flip on
all the lights that's going to keep you
up for a few more hours wake up the rest
of the family the motion sensor
NightLight you get within five feet of
that thing the bowl is perfectly lit
you go back to bed I think that's
actually great 10 bucks on Amazon
changed my life change my family tree I
gotta tell you
I got no problems with it
get through the interview process I'll
tell you how it took zero phds I'll tell
you that much yeah I know
watch out
he made the tall joke I had to get him
back
that thing is so weird
um I I
I'm just trying to say this in the right
way
I don't need my pathlets I can I get my
aim is true is what I will say
[Applause]
you I I thought you were going to say
dog bed
the pet ramp was very very controversial
to John and Ken I will not get into the
pet ramp would have joined that group
yeah but he wants to know what Dave all
right Dave I don't know I'm trying to
think you have to tell us I mean mainly
what it would be would just be the
volume of something I do that would be
embarrassing like I you know if I want
to get if I start collecting something I
collect way too much of it like I
started doing old water skis antique
water skis and now like they filled up
the whole freaking basement and my
wife's like they're killing me they hit
the car this is all and and they're
everywhere they're like they're you know
so everything I do I just I go OCD and I
you know I've got well no but I mean you
know whatever else you know gun
collection way too many Firearms way too
many Firearms what's the thing Sharon
there's not going to be a one I don't
know think like you think like no no
it's a lot
it's just I mean I just do whatever it
is the amount is what's embarrassing I
just don't that's fair I don't I don't
turn it off I mean I got like three pair
of jeans I'm good with that but when I
do something else there's 8 000 of them
you know whatever it is you know it's
like and I got too many cars you know I
have too many of this you know and it's
just like it's just it's stupid
contentment
[Music]
um
no it's not about it's not about
contentment it's not like it's bringing
me joy it's just I'm OCD and I can't
stop
that's good I think we were all guilty I
think we all had yeah I think we'd be
all fair insertive because sometimes
well we're all human I have no guilt
about the body pillow
and if anyone works for George underwear
I would like to you to sponsor my show
new sponsors really be a sponsor because
it's really not called Jewel also please
don't say Joy
oh it says a blanket State I realize how
that can be used this evening can go
sideways it's gonna tackle you if you
stood up and tried to show us
[Music]
okay okay let me wrap us up here yes
welcome to a Ramsey staff meeting okay
oh my gosh okay
um that was fantastic hey it's wrap us
up though tonight for Real uh Dave I'd
love
um as we end just to give a piece of
encouragement right we're entering a new
year we've talked about fears we've
talked about good habits what to do to
build wealth uh there's been a lot of
information tonight so end us this event
which is some encouragement some hope
I I think the uh
I think for sure this idea that you step
back and you get perspective
uh what Rachel's showing you for
instance on the graphs with the S P 500
or you step back and it it is one of the
uh benefits of getting old is I know I
didn't die from that
that I thought that thing was going to
be the end of the world it wasn't that
was that was going to be no that's not
the in the world and that was going to
be the end of the world and the number
of times that I've had people predict
that Jesus was coming back on a certain
year and it didn't happen you know I
mean I just they're all wrong apparently
and so
um they don't know in other words which
the Bible says that but the the point
being is we get caught up in the drama
of the moment and when you step back
from it and put it in perspective
it's silly it's almost humorous
uh what we were losing our hope over
what we were losing our minds over don't
sweat the small stuff and it's all
small stuff
uh because you know I mean that I'm
gonna lose the truck it's a truck
there's a lot of them
you know you get another one I mean I've
been to a lot of funerals I've never
seen a router truck following a hearse
you know you're not taking it with you
it's just stuff and so stepping back and
going all right there's some things here
that are really important that I'm
willing to sacrifice for and other
people aren't going to understand and
I'm going to do it anyway
I'm gonna do it anyway
I'm not I'm not taking a poll here this
is not a popularity contest we're going
to do it anyway and that's that hope
that comes from perspective is what we
want for all of you it's why we did this
tonight it's what everything is telling
us from the culture right now that's
going on that we needed to tell you all
tonight and that's why we came that's
why we wanted to do this for a couple
hundred thousand people online and a
thousand or so here in our building and
that's why we'll be on the air tomorrow
on the Ramsay show doing the exact same
thing again not this material but we're
going to be telling you it's okay you're
going to get there you've got to follow
proven principles you cannot violate the
law of gravity and expect anything but
pain don't do it it hurts it's stupid
don't do it you're not stupid but you're
doing stupid stop it and it gives people
hope and Clarity and uh and that's what
we wanted to do tonight and and I hope I
pray we've done that if not leave here
knowing that that's available to you
that you've just got to reach and get it
thanks for being here tonight everybody
God bless y'all
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign